hi everyone
welcome to the cloud operations
spotlight
my name is banjo chinana i'm one of the
leads for cloud ops
focused on monitoring hi everyone my
name is rami shalom
and i'm a pm lead in cloud operations
focusing on logging and apm
today we're going to talk about
collaborations in google we're going to
recap
about everything that we have done uh in
the past year
we're going to demonstrate the most
exciting features so we'll be able to
experience this
more uh accurately and then we're going
to talk about our road map the new
exciting things that we're going to work
on in the next year
and some customer highlights how they
actually use the product and just
so what is cloud ops and what happened
to stock driver
so we rebranded and with this rebranding
we have done some significant changes in
the product to justify this reframing
so cloud operations is still a split of
products designed to monitor
troubleshoot and operate your services
at scale
cloud operations help developers and
operators so you guys
keep your application fast and available
the suite
includes three main products first one
is monitoring
monitoring is the framework to be able
to monitor your
metrics dashboards uptime checks and
alerts
whereas logging is a platform that
allows you to manage your mods
analyze them and get the most value out
of them and then we have traces
which allows you to manage your trace
one more
piece to mention here is that those
products are part of a
single suite that allow you to do
cross-signal coordination
why don't you tell us about how scalable
this platform is
yeah you know folks may be asking like
what makes us so different
from every other product out there and
look
these products were born from inside
google so
a lot of the capabilities you see here
today were actually developed
for google by google and what we're
doing is exposing those same
capabilities to you
our customers and so the scale at which
google operates
as you can imagine is quite large we've
taken that same scalable back-end
infrastructure
and we've now oriented that to you our
customers
so we can provide you the same planet
level scale that we provide to our own
websites to our own capabilities and our
own applications
now some of the some of the stats that
might astound you about how much
data we take in today 50 trillion
point metric points uh in memory are
stored for
all the ingest volume that comes in
and we've got over two and a half
exabytes per month of logs that enter
the system and that can be analyzed so
this just gives you an idea of the type
of scale that we can operate at
now along with that scale what we've
been able to do is ensure
that when you stand up your services on
google cloud
that you don't have to put much effort
into ensuring that logging
and monitoring and our advanced
observability capabilities are available
on the first day you start out so
there's built-in capabilities
for all of your google cloud services
and xero config
needed to get those up and running so
that the
first day that a new google service
comes up the next google cloud offering
you'll have all the metrics and logs for
all those services available
as soon as it is ga
let's talk a little bit about what we've
been doing since
last year at next 2019.
we really took a focus on cloud ops
around three big areas
the first was around enterprise
readiness we wanted to make sure
that our capabilities allow for
you our customers to comply
with all of your corporate regulations
and compliance rules that you need
in order to make sure it fully
integrates with the systems that you
already have today
so whether it's providing longer term
retention
for logs and metrics or whether it's
deeper integration into third-party
systems
we provided a lot of the capabilities
that make sure that
you can tie this in to the systems that
you already have
and make that transition to the cloud
that much easier
we focused on ease of use we wanted to
make sure that the products are easy
and simple to use for even non-power
users for those that
are using wallets and metrics and traces
for the first time
and so you'll see a lot of the work
we've done to simplify the user
interface
and to make it easier to get to the root
cause of what's going on
in your systems and lastly we focused on
jcp
we wanted to make sure that every
service on gcps
all the logs and the metrics that are
necessary to troubleshoot what's going
on with
with the infrastructure that you now
rely on are available to you on day one
and so we deeply integrated with all the
gcp services
from bigquery to google compute engine
to gke or kubernetes engine and a
variety of other services so on day zero
all of those are are reading available
for you
let's look at one of those integrations
we did for ease of use
we took the entire cloud monitoring
console that was previously
in a separate ui in a separate browser
we brought that into the google cloud
console in the same context
as all the other services use compute
engine bigquery
gke with that in context
capability you now have full visibility
to all of your metrics
and we improved a number of the
interfaces around
cloud monitoring so it's easier to get
your dashboards to your alerts
into your uptime checks for one single
place and you can very easily then
switch back and forth between cloud
monitoring
and all the rest of your google cloud
services
romi why don't you talk a little bit
about some of the work we did in the log
viewer as well
thanks banjo similar to what we have
done on the monitoring side
we have invested heavily in the log
viewer
we actually rebuilt the product from the
ground up uh to optimize it for
performance and responsiveness so your
experience with the new
blog viewers should be way better and
easier to work with
we also invested in some key components
that will allow you to better analyze
your data
get the essence of what you're
experiencing and really looking for in
your logs
directly from the ui that you have there
so we invested in the histogram that
allows you to see the time
uh distribution of your logs so we'd be
able to see exactly when there is a
spike of errors
we've invested in the log field explorer
to allow you to see aggregation of your
logs based on field values so this gives
you a highlight view of everything that
happens there
we have invested in how streaming
operates we're going to talk about this
a bit later
we have invested in a query library that
will allow you to
manage your queries because you want to
repeat your work sometimes and get some
recommendation about that
we have done a bunch of other things
we're going to talk about
other than that we also created a new
log dashboard
this is a great example of how you do
the how we do the integration between
monitoring logging and traces in this
case
it's producing a dashboard that is
focusing on logs
inside the logging ui but relying on the
metrics that happen in cloud management
why don't you tell us about slo
monochrome
yeah slo monitoring is a great new
feature we've added to really help you
reduce the signal to noise ratio so
as you add more and more signals uh
whether it's metrics and logs from
your from your existing workloads it
gets it gets harder and harder to really
find the root cause of what's happening
and really what we want to do is ensure
that our services
are being measured by how our users are
experiencing those services
service level objectives is is focused
on doing
exactly that it's ensuring that you look
at the same measurements and experience
it the same way
as your users do by automatically
ingesting the services that are created
on your gke deployed applications
whether it be through gka labels and
main spaces
or if you're using our advanced
capabilities with
istio and antho service mesh we
automatically find those services
and then you can quickly create
availability and performance metrics
and collect those to create your service
level indicators
to which you can then apply an objective
and a threshold
that you can alert on what this also
does is allows you to see
a single view of that service so you can
see all the entities that compose that
service
and all the signals related to those
entities the logs the metrics and the
traces
all in one place and we give you that
single pane of glass to ensure that you
can troubleshoot that service
and quickly get to resolution on any
issue that you might be experiencing
now we've also made this easier for our
system administrators and our it
operators
who have to go through and instrument
all of their applications and all of
their
vms to ensure they can collect those
metrics we provided this new
ops config agent where you can define
the automation lifecycle
for this agent itself and ensure that
the right vms get the right agents with
the right versions
and they're automatically installed and
that policy is enforced throughout
all of your vm instances and you see a
sample policy command here
that defines which which vms
in this case all vms yet installed
agents that are particular to the
logging and monitoring agents
the versions of those agents and you can
decide whether those pages
automatically upgrade when new versions
are available
and then lastly for our power users we
added the new metrics query language
this gives users who who are really
taking their metrics to a new level and
looking to do
much more complicated alerting and
mathematical operations on time series
data
provides them the ability to to perform
those operations
by doing things like allowing you to do
ratios and time shift on your data to do
month over month
or year over year analysis or in the
case of ratios
to be able to define say certain new
service level indicators for your
service
it allows for complex grouping and
filtering so you can take that data
and and pivot it in a number of
different ways depending on the metric
labels you have
and the types of resources that you're
looking at so
this really enables power users to find
what they need
within the time series data they get and
the more data you collect
the easier it is to use the metrics
query language
to look and sift through that data to
find what you're looking for
all right we've also invested on the
power u in the power users
in the login framework one notable
feature
maybe looking tiny but quite requested
by our customers by you guys
is the ability to use regular
expressions within the wrong queries so
today it's available
you're able to use regular expressions
to identify patterns
and make your queries more specific and
more efficient to find exactly what
you're looking for
and we've seen tremendous traction with
customers using that feature
other than that many of you have been
asking us to add the streaming feature
into the log viewer
so we didn't just do that we actually
decided to
invest in it further so we created a new
api
in the product that allows you to get a
much better latency
from 13 seconds waiting for logs now
you're gonna wait for less than two
seconds
the way it's done is that we have
shortcutted some of the steps along the
ingestion
pipeline flogs and get them straight to
the ui for you to be able to ingest
those logs and see them right in the ui
so you're not going to wait for them
when you're running your code it's going
to appear as soon as the application
generates them
the next one is log buckets one of the
key features that customers have been
asking us
is to manage the logs in a way that fits
their needs in a better way
more specifically log buckets is a new
construct that allows you to store the
logs first of all in a centralized
fashion you can collect all the logs
from all the projects that you have and
put them in one bucket if you wish
in a way that will allow you to uh
centralize your logs
however buckets is also allowing you to
do the the other way around which is
basically decentralize everything you
may want to have a bucket or
a scope of logs dedicated per
application so what buckets are going to
give you data enablement as well
other than that log buckets as a
physical contract can be stored
regionally which means you can decide
that a certain bucket is not going to
leave a certain region
that's good for compliance purposes in
some regions but it also is useful for
the case of redundancy
you may want to have uh fault tolerance
between two different regions
you can put the same data into different
buckets
and store it into different regions the
last piece
is that the log buckets will allow us
also to offer you granular permissions
for those buckets
so you'd be able to decide which users
can access which logs
assigned in which bucket and we actually
intend to do more than that
we are going to introduce the concept of
log views which will allow you to get
even more granular access control
in the box for in each and every bucket
the last piece i'm going to mention
related to uh to apm
is cross signal correlation across
traces
metrics and logs right now you'll be
able to see
that we are going to be able to access
metrics sorry traces
right from your monitoring dashboards
or right from your logs whenever they
are available and you're going to get
a sense that this is actually available
you're going to get the signal that the
trace is available and you can click on
it and see exactly the
the waterfall of the of the latency that
happens inside your application
and with that why don't we go through a
quick demo to show the main
features that we are doing in the
product welcome everybody
in this demo we will walk you through
the new and the most exciting features
in google cloud operations
we have been working on for the past
year
as you will see we have been working
hard to improve your experience and
productivity as you observe and
troubleshoot your
applications we will start our journey
in cloud monitoring and we'll focus our
attention
on services in this page
you will notice a range of services some
of them are automatically identified by
the systems and others were defined by
the users
let's focus our attention on those
services that look like that
could deserve some attention more
specifically let's focus our attention
on ad service
this service appears to be in distress
in the sense that it's not
meeting our service level level
objective and we want to take a closer
look at what's happening
at the top of the page you will notice
the alert timeline
component this component allows you to
review
all the alerts that have been fired for
this service
along this timeline and drill down as
needed
below the alert timeline you will notice
the slo
component this component allows you to
review
slos that have been defined for this
service it also allows you to create a
new slo
by choosing the metrics of your choice
as well as the criteria of your choice
in this case we can notice that the
service the ad service
is out of error budget which means it
deserves our attention and we need to
drill down further to see
what's going on below the slo component
you will notice the key metrics
component this component presents to you
the metrics that are collected for this
service
you can review those metrics at multiple
levels depending on what you're looking
for
you can do it at the container at the
pod or the node level
these key metrics can offer valuable
insights about what may be wrong with
your service
so that could be a good starting point
to further explore
or troubleshoot your service
below the metrics widget you will notice
the logs widget
this widget allows you to explore the
logs that are produced by this service
which can provide valuable context
related to every issue
that this service is experiencing
for greater details and deeper analysis
of those logs
you can choose to open the logs in the
log viewer
we will begin our journey in cloud
logging by presenting the key components
on the page
the first one is the log viewer or where
the logs are actually presented
this is where you'll see all the logs
that are collected by the system and
you'll be able to browse through that
you will then notice the histogram which
gives you a time-based distribution of
the logs that are presented below
lastly there is the log field explorer
this widget
presents to you an aggregation view
based on field values in the logs
that appear in the log widget
to begin our troubleshooting journey we
will start with
selecting the resource that is of
interest to us based on the logs that we
see
i'm interested in kubernetes containers
i'm going to click that and you will
notice that this resource is now added
to the query
also i'm interested in errors that are
happening in my
application so i'm going to click that
as well and you will notice that there
is a cluster of errors that appear at
different points in time
along the last six hours at this point
we may choose to narrow the results down
further
based on the time range that we are
interested in the most
or we can simply focus on the logs that
appear on screen because the number
is small enough at this point we can
just
get rid of everything else other than
logs and focus just on the mods that
appear on screen
another option to reach this narrow set
of results
could be via the log dashboard
the long dashboard is a component that
allows you to see
an aggregation of logs over time based
on specific resources and specific types
of logs
on the left side you'll see the overall
logs that are generated the resource
on the right side you will notice the
errors that are generated for this
service
this dashboard allows you to click on
one of those
bars and view the logs that are related
to that what will happen is that we'll
jump
to the log viewer presenting the errors
or the the logs that are related to the
specific bar that i selected
you'll probably notice that up to this
point i didn't even interact with the
query builder
which allows me to actually edit the
specific text
inside the query and construct it the
way i want to
you can further adjust your query by
either editing the text directly
in the query builder and change any of
the fields that appear there
or use the menus to construct your query
based on
the resources the log name or the
severity
of the logs that you're interested in
you'll also notice a new functionality
that we have added to manage your
queries
beside the query builder you will notice
a query library that allows you
to review your recent queries and
relaunch them if you want to
save queries queries that you decided to
save and share with other users in the
project
and suggested queries those are queries
that we actually suggest to you
based on our understanding of your logs
last but not least i would like to turn
your attention to the streaming
functionality
in the log viewer this feature
allows you to visualize logs
as they are being generated by the
application the delay time is
seconds which allows you to troubleshoot
your applications way more efficiently
thanks for listening we will now go back
to the presentation and continue our
discussion
focusing on the roadmap for cloud
operations
that was a great demo rami thanks for
that let's now talk about what's coming
next for cloud ops we've got some
exciting new features that we think will
make it really easy for our users
to now take advantage of all the great
capabilities
in our product suite we'll start with
simplified dashboard and alert creation
you know we find that many users have a
hard time
getting to their first dashboard because
they don't know what metrics to use
they don't quite know how to visualize
those metrics in a way
that makes sense so we provided a basic
mode
that allows you to get a guided
prescriptive flow
to deciding which metrics to choose
using the most commonly
uh access metrics for your gcp services
and then providing recommendations for
how to visualize
those metrics in a chart that makes
sense to you
we'll also provide the advanced
capabilities so you can continue to
use the dials and knobs to get all the
right alignment
and grouping and filtering that you need
to to get the most out of your data
as you become more and more advanced on
your usage
of the dashboard capabilities
and of course you'll have the query
language to do even
more complex queries and arithmetic
operations that you can't do through the
user interface
we provide a grid-based layout so you
can quickly drag and drop your
charts wherever you want to and make
sure that right charts get the right
attention they stay in the right place
or they can get sized as big or as small
as you need them to
and we've added additional chart types
so you can use things like heat maps
to find out where problems are in a very
complicated
metric series or bar charts scorecards
and other text based placeholders to
make your charts work for you
we're also looking forward to providing
additional multi-signal correlation
using topology information today
we can take a look at all the
microservices that you've got running
in your gke cluster as an example and
map that out
in this topology graph that topology
graph will give you a great sense
of the dependency between your micro
services and which service is
communicating with whichever service
now that's great for configuration and
for looking at
static display but what we'd really like
to do
is layer on additional information about
latency
service up time and error rates so you
can quickly diagnose and find the
problems that matter
between your microservices and as it
gets more and more complicated
across your your real estate about your
applications
we can use the topology graph to
simplify where to look
and how to find the right problem to
solve for
and then with proactive alerts and
remediation
we want to be able to really get the
system to work for you instead of just
working alongside you so with automatic
automated alert creation
the system will recommend the types of
alerts you should create
for the gcp services that you have so on
day zero
you have the best practices
configuration ready to go
you can of course configure those alerts
in ways that make sense to you
but at least you provided the
recommended way to look at a service
that you may be looking at for the first
time
with log base alerts you'll be able to
quickly get notifications on events that
happen
inside your logs so instead of having to
turn those logs into metrics
and then explore them through the
metrics explorer
you can now just assign alerts based on
patterns
and combinations you see in the
structure of the logs themselves
with alert remediation we can now do
typical workflow functions
so as an alert fires wouldn't it be
great if the system
just handled some of the common issues
for you so when a cpu when a vm runs out
of cpu
or it runs out of disk why not just
resize the vm
if you have bad deployment in gke and
the application is continuing to
to service and throw errors why not
redeploy
based on the last known good state of
that application
or something more complicated that
you've already
triaged and understand how to fix you
can write your own cloud function
and execute that from the alerts
themselves
and lastly with anomaly based alerting
we really want the system to work for
you
and really get ahead of problems before
they become problems
so anomaly based on learning will
threshold or baseline the system
and set automated thresholds for when we
see the system
deviating from normals that we are
viewing
year over year month over month or day
of your day and this is leveraging
all of the great machine learning
capabilities inside of google
romney why don't you tell us a little
bit about what's happening on the log
side of the house
thanks man wow you have a lot going on
let's talk what's happening on the
logging site then so
we will continue the effort of making
the inside our blogs
more readily available for you to use at
this point
you know it's more following your leads
when it comes to
uh what logs you're looking for our
plans forward is to drive those
insights out of the box without you
trying to figure out what's going on so
for instance
when we see a certain scope of logs in
your log viewer
we will surface proactively the trends
that are related to this
if there is if there is a bunch of
errors that you will want to be aware of
or a resource that is an outstanding uh
resource or if there is a field that we
see that
is uh uh providing a certain insight
that we will want to service to you
those are the types of things we're
going to show you out of the box within
cloud blogging using visual
mechanisms to do that
but maybe more importantly one of the
key investments that we have right now
in cloud logging
is our analytics this
is a smart analytics at cloud scale
using sql relying on bigquery
so the idea is that first of all we want
to allow you to have a richer language
to analyze your logs
in some cases you will want to do more
than just
filtering of your logs we want you to do
aggregations
and allow you to do more sophisticated
operations on your logs
for that you will need sql we will use
uh
bigquery as a backhand to be able to run
sql operations in cloud logging in the
context and all the power and
visualization that we have in our
we will also allow you to use the same
data in the login
that is going to be useful for you as
part of your bigquery analysis so for
instance if you want to do business
analytics involving multiple
repositories of data
you will be able to do this so combining
log data for instance with identities or
combining log data
with other parts of your business data
is going to be available
inside bigquery and seamlessly from
cloud volume
performance improvement rely on the fact
that we will be able to use the bigquery
framework
to do better indexing and the analysis
of bigger chunks of data
at faster rates this is one of the
things that bigquery is really powerful
at and we want to make sure that we
fully leverage that capability as part
of our cloud logging
uh capabilities as well
banjot why don't you tell us about how
customers are using our features
yeah it's you know it's great to have
customers really tell the story because
we as product managers we of course love
our products and we love building these
capabilities
but really it's up to our customers to
tell us whether these features make
sense or don't make sense so don't take
our word for it
hear their stories they're all talking
here at cloud next
so i'll call out a couple of customers
here that
we've been working closely with that are
really taking advantage of some of our
capabilities
with equifax shopify wix and
schlumberger
each have their own story how they've
leveraged parts of the cloud ops suite
and are taking advantage of the
capabilities we have today
so look for them in their respective
sessions
and of course there's a whole series of
tracks and other sessions
from which you can learn more about
everything we've talked about in our
cloud
spotlight session today so if you want
more information
or you want to hear directly from our
customers and hear more about
what your peers are doing in the
industry these are the tracks in which
you can find more information
between the infrastructure and app
modernization tracks who think you'll
find
a ton of great information
and with that we thank you for your time
today and we hope you get the most
out of this session as well as the rest
of the tracks through cloud next
thank you everyone and thanks for
staying with us
you